hey Nicole hi how are you I'm good i
I've always wanted to talk to you you're
always in Vancouver I'm in here in
Toronto so this is a good way to get to
talk to you yes absolutely
how are you holding up with this whole
self isolation are you a creative person
who's spending your time busying
yourself
yeah totally I'm doing a bunch of
fulfilling things you know I'm learning
so many new trades it's a lie I'm
sleeping I'm doing nothing of substance
or value and I love every second of it
I feel like introverts everywhere we're
like right
I mean service David congratulations on
everything you all had some great years
with Supergirl um but what I find that
is so incredible is that you oughta
making history and like that word we
can't say that with everybody like you
have made history and many cases you of
course had the bathroom case with the
get the bill that's which is made
history and of course you're playing the
first transgender superhero on
television what does it mean to you now
that you had a bit of time for not to
sink in what does it mean to make
history
I am also a trans woman I'm different
miss Danvers but so is everybody and I
don't know when that became such a bad
thing I don't know it's a weird thing to
think about something you're doing being
so monumental because you know I I just
kind of look at it and I'm just like I'm
a superhero
this is pretty cool right and and then
on you know just to put on top of that
how monumental it is it's I mean it's
such an honor that to get to do this for
the community and to be that there's so
many beautiful she's not just hurt and
humiliated she's heartbroken
she thought this guy really liked her
and he was just targeting her because
she was trans he's trying to use her to
get to dream her seeing how many people
have really grown attached to Judea and
to dreamer and how many people love her
as a character has been so rewarding and
so I'm so proud of it I'm so so proud of
how people have come to love this
character it's such an incredible
experience and it's such I think a
brilliant way to talk about these issues
the greatest gift we can give each other
is our authentic selves and sharing that
sharing our truth is what will make us
strong every time we have somebody who
comes out to Supergirl on set they're
like they're incredible it's amazing the
vibe there is just you are all really
friends there's such incredible people
and there aside from being stupid
talented they're all just such amazing
people and there's so all of them are so
cool and so I mean anyone would be lucky
to have them as friends all I feel like
I've seen to hear is people like it's
not like this everywhere because it's
not like it's not like it's you know
we're really lucky and I'm like I
haven't tasted that yet I think I'm Gary
I keep feeling like I'm gonna walk onto
step one day and like someone's gonna
like open hand like just slap me in the
face I know you can't tell me much but
now that were friends what can you tell
me about the remainder of the season
give me a little tea okay so we've had
all of these storylines in terms I get
ready for like here
so we've had all of these storylines
kind of a little all over the place we
had like goodbye then we had Andre a
Rojas and lex luthor's doing his whole
thing and Lena's been working with him
and now brainy's been working with them
and everyone's kind of off doing their
own thing and it's kind of like how is
this all connected
yeah and so heading into the end of
season five it's like someone just I
don't know like pulled on a rope and
everything just like hmm and you're like
oh bird Mia and for dreamer we've had
her you know she's had her moment her
breakdown yes she felt very attacked
we're gonna talk about Drive that's a
drag race but she had her moment and so
now she has kind of lit all of that
bubble up to the surface and she has
kind of lit that all out she can start
to move forward she still feels bad but
now that it's out there now that she's
talked about it she can start to move
forward she's not bottling that up so
we're gonna start seeing her dreams play
a bigger part we're going to start
seeing her in a dream larger things with
bigger consequence and so really her
problem moving forward is how is she
going to separate Cook own personal
issues from what she's seeing in her
visions will we fetch in drag race I
interview a lot of drag queens I am a
huge RuPaul's Drag Race fan are you
watching season 12 right now okay we're
gonna have a quick little Kiki who who
are you rooting for on season 12
currently right now okay that's right
now Jan Gigi Widow I think it's so
cheeky I love it she actually follows me
on Instagram and I met message to her ID
enter I'm like do not change your name
like oh I'm like stick to your guns like
if you like it
stick with it it's fabulous and I do
think the judges are sleeping on Jack
every single week Jim Gray executed the
talent visible it's all very loud
presence I would love to see a superhero
challenge and I would love to see you on
that judging panel one day I would love
it Kyler's win it Kyler watches it - so
we put it out to the universe and for
season 13 we thought is gonna happen
oh we have I want like good yes judge oh
hey there if you want more LGBTQ news
and exclusive interviews click Subscribe
or watch these videos